the author of the best-selling book
vengeance former Speaker of the House
Fox News contributor Newt Gingrich is
with us they didn't want the information
released in the beginning and as I this
is pretty powerful this letter of Devon
newness the House Intelligence Committee
chair he's basically confirming what
others what I suspect for a long time
that the Hillary Clinton bought and paid
for dossier was used in part during a
election season
to get a FISA warrant to spy on an
opposition party and then an incoming
president none of it was verified if
that happened and we find out that
happens what would that mean to you well
I mean you have two things right here
that are I think fascinating the first
is it turns out there may have been
collusion to undermine the American
presidential election by a government
bureaucracy it just turns out that the
bureaucracy wasn't Russian it was
American and that it was the Department
of Justice senior leadership and the FBI
senior leadership now that at one level
is a really frightening insight about
the future and about the danger of a
powerful police force deciding for the
rest of us which politicians are going
to go after the second thing that hit me
though as you were talking is there's
this new movie out which glorifies the
Washington Post the printing of
government documents the courage of the
post leadership you go back and take the
whole period of the Pentagon Papers the
attitude of the New York Times The
Washington Post isn't it interesting
that none of these papers are coming in
and making the same demands of course we
should publish this of course the
American people should see it where's
the losses there's a right to know maybe
it'll be Hannity and company that has to
file the lawsuit to get some of this
information that the really dangerous
thing here and I'm making a very strong
distinction because I have such great
respect for the FBI and the DOJ and
intelligence but the powerful tools of
intelligence we now have to get Isis and
al-qaeda and and enemies of this country
if we turn it and politicize it and spy
on opposition party can it
and use that information to destroy
people we've we've lost the country mr.
speaker that's how serious that is to me
Wow look there's a whole pattern going
back at least to the 1970s of people on
the Left who were genuinely worried that
an intelligent state during the Cold War
would acquire so much power that it
could actually subvert the whole process
it said that almost none of those people
are now speaking out about the current
problem because the intellipedia with
you entirely this is this is all a thin
layer of largely politically appointed
type people it's not the great bulk of
hard-working everyday folks out there
trying to protect America and trying to
enforce the law but this thin layer I
think we're going to discover the next
few days
clearly conspired to mislead a judge in
order to get an ability to spy which was
totally illegal and I think that's part
of why you saw McCabe leave I think
you're gonna see some more people leave
I'm really shocked the strike is still
there I mean after all the stuff we
learned about him I don't know why he's
not gone already and I think you're
gonna see more people have to leave and
then you're gonna see whether or not in
fact they get involved in a serious
criminal investigation because a lot of
what they were doing wasn't just unwise
it was illegal and they were really
threatening the freedom and the rights
of the American people but you know
what's amazing about this is this this
dossier infusion GPS said in testimony
that was before the Senate committee
they never verified it Hillary Clinton
never verified it then before the house
Intel committee Fuzion GPS is suggesting
they tried to shop the salacious you
know stories of hookers and and in
ritz-carlton and Trump and urinating in
bed they they were shopping it and
coordinating with the Clinton campaign
now Hillary Clinton clearly fixed a
primary she tried to use the dossier to
lie to the American people in a general
that dossier was used to get a warrant
against an opposition candidate and
we've had a year of Trump Russia
collusion and no evidence and the media
in this country has ignored I would
argue that
his story in their lifetime this is
bigger than Watergate
that's like water gates like stealing a
Snickers bar from a candy store a drug
store in comparison what am I is this
hyperbole or my answer I mean I'm not
sure I'm quite into the Snickers bar
versus say stealing an entire automobile
but I know where you're going with this
III think it's in a remember the elite
media is part of the deep State the
elite media group has survived by being
in collusion with the senior bureaucracy
the city of Washington the senior
reporters the senior bureaucrats the
senior lobbyists they all hang out
together they all talk to each other
they all compare notes but it is you're
exactly right about the scale of this
and this is what people that wouldn't
when they get to read this but the
American people need to understand is
that the Obama administration in a
series of steps that clearly violated
the law tried to both protect Hillary
Clinton and try to destroy Donald Trump
and both actions were illegal and we're
now in a situation I believe where
you're going to see a requirement in the
near future for an independent council
literally to clean out the senior FBI
and the senior Justice Department and to
go after people who've left office who
were part of the Obama team that was so
clearly violating the law what do you
make of this massive disconnect the
president has a State of Union address
we have great news
we've got 2.4 million new jobs we got 2
million fewer people that are on food
stamps the president gives all the this
great economic success people are now
building factories and manufacturing
centers and taxes are down Americans are
getting a lot more money starting
February 1st in their pocket he's trying
to keep the country secure you get one
reaction from the news media and you get
another reaction even with a CBS poll
and the CNN poll you know that shows
something very different what we're what
do you say about that disconnect well I
keep telling you the elite meet in the
United States is not neutral they're not
referees or the offensive wing of the
other team and the elite median you saw
some of this in the clips you had some
of which are frankly outrageously
anti-trump in a way that's almost
bizarre these are folks who are so
deeply hostile to what Donald Trump is
trying to accomplish that they are fully
as much a part of the opposition as is
Nancy Pelosi or Chuck Schumer and that's
part of why you're getting this
unbelievably biased coverage I must say
when I watched last night and I saw the
president say we have the lowest black
unemployment in history and nobody the
black caucus could applaud I thought to
myself mean who are they loyal to if
they're not happy that their
constituents have a job if they're not
happy that the tax cuts really
dramatically help their congressional
districts then who do they represent and
I think this is a real challenge to the
entire left-wing ethnic leadership in
America we have that montage and a lot
more coming up